hey benjamibo good to see you hey
everybody here good to see you guys too
i'm glad to be here i got in on the
standing line so i'm really happy to be
here um do you know about the bill that
republicans are trying to pass to stop
critical race theory being taught in
college um i'm aware that there isabell
i haven't read the text of it but go
ahead
okay so in florida i think it's gonna go
oh i look sick um
so it's gonna be
decided i guess we're gonna talk about
it in like december um yeah in the new
legislative session correct yes
so as a republican being pro free speech
do you have anything to say against this
like we're really
simply just outlawing certain words to
be used
in public spheres such as education
um i feel like more republicans should
kind of seem see this as concerning you
know you guys always quote uh 18 and
1984 or whatever
um you know this is like an orwellian
move isn't it so so it depends on what
level of education we're talking about
if we're talking about the idea that
critical race theory can be taught as
one of many theories on college campuses
i have no problem with it marxism is
taught as one of many theories on
college campuses if the idea is that
we're going to be teaching critical race
theory which is not taught as one of
many theories it's taught as a framework
for understanding the world and it is a
lens through which we are to view
history this is something that the
founders of critical race theory openly
acknowledge they suggest the critical
race theory has a praxis component
meaning it's a practice component that
is designed in order to indoctrinate
kids in a particular type of thinking
about how america's institutions work do
i think that the taxpayers of the state
of florida have an obligation to
subsidize the indoctrination of their
children in that no and i think that
public education as an institution is
dedicated not merely to the idea that
you send your kids to school and then
the teachers dump whatever they want on
your kids i think the idea is that these
the parents delegate their power to
educate their children to the state
via the public schools and then they
have the authority and should have the
authority to determine what framework is
being taught and the anti-american
framework of critical race theory which
is unrooted in actual history ought not
be taught in america's public schools
um
like critical race theory is literally a
footnote in my sociology class and it's
a framework if you want to take it in as
a framework listen i learned critical
race theory and i was at harvard law
school too right i mean i i in fact
whenever you talk about critical race
theory you say the right things you know
what you're talking about but because
you're a republican it's the talking
point to go against no they are i'm a
pro
free speech american so this deeply
concerns me when there are
words exact words that are being
restricted
in the public sphere well that's why i
just ended up by saying marketplace of
ideas so i'm a big marketer right so i i
again i would distinguish between
marketplace of ideas in the college
realm and when presumably people are old
enough to actually understand what
they're talking about have open and
interesting debates about these topics
and when you're talking about 11 year
olds or 10 year olds or when you're
talking about reading ibra max kenny
which is a really dumbed down version of
critical race theory for five-year-olds
i'd be happy to look at the text of the
bill and determine what i think about
the bill i do think that public schools
i'm not sure the public schools have an
obligation to teach as practical
critical race theory again i think there
are different ways that it's taught so
if we're talking about just
intersociology classes one of many
theories about american history and now
we're going to talk about how it applies
i don't really have a problem with that
being taught if we're talking about
critical race theory being taught as a
framework to view america's institutions
to the exclusion of other frameworks i
do have a problem with that
thank you